I'm gonna have to tell like everyone I
meet that I'm just holding it for my
girlfriend it doesn't exist a week ago
to help with video production I got a
fanny pack so I figured this is just a
slippery slope there's a very fine line
between feminine purses and man bags so
whatever I feel like I'm gonna leave it
somewhere and lose all my [ __ ] and I'm
expecting that I might get locked out
I'm actually excited I'll finally have a
place to put my sunscreen this is my
color for sure but it's also a bright
green purse this one's more of a winter
what do you think would look good with
me this one would be a statement piece
oh maybe I should be different and just
get this one if you're gonna do
something in life you gotta go big so
I'm gonna take of the red purse this
seems the neutralist of the bunch so I'm
gonna be a wimp and go for this one I
think I can never find anything in here
this is awesome it feels like Hanukkah
or something at my wallet I got the
giant iPhone Salinas gum wrapper I'll
bet I'm the only person doing this who
the first thing they put in is a knife
can I fit this in here I oh I can week
from now I expect to have a full-on
rain poncho in here I actually think I
might be able to handle this so it's
been like five minutes since I got the
person I've already put my phone in my
pocket twice I actually got a lot of
compliments on this chris is working
thing thank you
I can't even tell its first Akita
rocking a person public you got to rock
the walk
disappointing
I don't cheat either didn't notice for
the first it's just like hey this is not
her first man first he does Audrey why
did you laugh at me earlier today in
class so I am doing laundry as soon as I
get in here there's this gorgeous girl
in a bikini top and just being super
nice and high and friendly and I
immediately go to hide it
that's right world I'm riding a scooter
with a fashionable handbag deal with it
when I was at home my mom asked me
specifically to not bring my purse with
me because you know she was concerned
that I was going to be made fun of it
you know in Hollywood but most people
really don't care I think in other parts
of the world this experiment wouldn't
even be able to happen because it would
just be way too much for two people that
nobody would want to do it you know
let's unbag my keys and my wallet and my
phone this is such a great place to keep
your receipt vick's vapo rub I have free
USB charger hello a change of clothes I
can carry this around with me in case I
need to change t-shirt never carried
hand lotion in my life some lipstick I
mean chapstick
oh gosh you guys don't have like a
socially acceptable place to keep your
condom and a copy of nineteen eighty
eight's big with Tom Hanks and if you're
like me you'll get one that's actually a
garden gnome with a pornographically
long member a week of wearing a purse
was a little easier than I was hoping
that they helped me be organizing in
that I know where each of my essentials
are I think I got like a couple jolly
smiles when I would be purchasing stuff
but I never fully lost the
self-consciousness of having a purse on
me I don't think I'd ever do it like
daily after this I'm actually
considering switching over to a bag of
this size that is the benefit the purse
all this I get to carry around with me
and I need all this stuff I'm amazed at
how strong the like gender bias is how
crazy of an idea is that and we just
called it the bag that everyone gets to
wear if you want to carry a purse do it
if you want to carry a man bag
or a satchel do that it's great but
please just let me use my packets again
my girlfriend was like oh my god whose
purse is that I was like oh I'm doing
this for a BuzzFeed video and explain
what it is and she's like oh my god
thank God I thought you got me a really
tacky purse it was like I picked this
out